what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another episode
of the power rangers mighty morphin
power rangers now in the last video that
we did
we basically had like all the power
rangers turn into green rangers
essentially right that's one of the
things we talked about i mean everybody
except for billy right you just kind of
had like this
crazy looking dragon zord more or less
they're called the black dragon that
came from a different dimension and was
basically working with rita repulsa and
that billy was captured presumably due
to his intelligence
and the rest of the rangers tommy and
jason and trini and kimberly and them
basically you were doing what they could
against like this mystery guy and so the
result of this is a couple things go on
one this black dragon guy had basically
cut off the power rangers access to the
morphin grid right so they couldn't
really do anything the only exception
was tommy because tommy
accessed the morphin grid essentially
through like a back door right and so it
couldn't necessarily be cut off by
conventional means and so in response to
that tommy basically gave the rest of
the power rangers his ability to tap
into the the green ranger energy making
them all green rangers at the expense of
his ability to tap into it in himself
right so tommy's not a power ranger at
the moment is basically what that means
and so what you end up getting here are
a couple things going on the first is
that we got a kind of timeline from rita
repulsa
basically telling the world if you don't
submit to my rule i'm going to conquer
you right i'm just going to raise your
cities and everything is going to come
crashing to the ground and of course
humanity chose to blow off reader
repulsion say like we're not going to to
give into this whole thing right and so
this basically had her by way of the
black dragon who essentially controls
the zords now since he controls the
morphin grid
basically dispersing the zords across
major cities around the world
to really just kind of make an example
of them right like what happens if you
do not submit to the rule of rita
repulsa
the problem with this is suddenly the
power rangers show up
[Laughter]
right jason shows up and all these guys
and it's kind of wild to see that they
can that they're basically green rangers
right it's just it's kind of strange to
me
i know that over the course of the
television history different characters
play different power rangers different
colors of rangers but still man it's
just weird i mean it's cool
it's really really cool but it's just
kind of strange to me to see like
a person who's a green ranger but has
the whole like really helmet design of
like the red ranger right so it just is
a little strange but the fact that they
can now access the morphin grid even if
it's doing it through tommy's energy
basically now means they can get their
zords back and so what you end up having
is essentially all of them basically
taking back all their zords right jason
takes back the tyrannosaurus and
kimberly takes back the pterodactyl and
trini takes back the saber two tigers so
on one of the things that also goes on
here is you've got
billy who's basically removed from the
equation billy's not really part of this
zach is of course right he's the
mastodon but billy's billy's triceratops
is essentially being controlled now
by the black dragon and admittedly the
triceratops is cool but it's really just
kind of a tank each one of the zords
kind of has their own capabilities but
the biggest issue you have with the
zords is that
individually they're not all that strong
the tyrannosaurus is cool the dragon
zord is really cool in and of itself but
the problem is that they're designed to
work in a situation where they're
greater than the sum of their parts
hence the megazord and so when you have
these individual zords kind of facing
off or you have like the triceratops
facing off because the tyrannosaurus and
the the
the saber-tooth tiger and the
pterodactyl and the mastodon there's not
a whole lot it can do
the whole situation is complicated even
further when tommy reveals that he still
has access to the dragonzord albeit he's
not really a ranger
so he can't really pilot it in the
traditional sense instead he's using his
dragon dagger right his flute he's
singing songs and winning the day
[Laughter]
but ultimately it's one of these things
where this this black dragon guy
is essentially cornered right he's got
like a triceratops at his disposal and
that kind of seems to be it and so what
you end up getting is this kind of
transition where you pick up with billy
and goldar and this is why i say the way
goldar is handled here is amazing
because normally goldars is kind of a
throwaway guy you know
it's a goldar right he was kind of a
goof from the tv show in the comic he's
amazing
and there's this really cool situation
where because they're in the dark
dimension
that's basically controlled by goldar
right i mean that's really what this is
goldar kind of decides what does and
doesn't go on there and that's kind of
the crazy thing is because in this
conversation that they're having
billy is largely observing everything
that's going on right in terms of like
this this kind of
viewing sphere more or less just sort of
observing every single thing that's
happening and there's a kind of
agreement right between him and goldar
where it's kind of like i mean
i'm not a huge fan of this black dragon
guy like what do you what do you think
and goldar is like no i don't really
like him either right like i'm not a
huge fan of this guy this guy came up
out of nowhere
and basically told rita repulsa he could
help her do what i could not hence the
reason why i'm imprisoned here
in the dark dimension so like i kind of
see this guy is a is a bigger
issue and that's when billy's kind of
like so you don't know anything about
this guy he's like no we don't know
anything about him all we know is like
his voice came from beyond
right some some place beyond the pines i
don't know and then in turn
rita repulsa decided to work with him
and that's when it's kind of like okay
so
goldar kind of hits this idea like he's
a lot more observant than they give him
credit for it and that's the cool
that's why i like the way he's done in
the comics right i mean a lot of you
guys who are my age right i'm 37 years
old a lot of you guys who are my age who
grew up with the mighty morphin power
rangers
goldar was a goof and then when you look
at this it's kind of like i mean no he's
really not like he's very very observant
and he's like i don't think that's his
true form and when billy's like what are
you talking about he's like he shrinks
and he grows at will
his armor basically builds around him so
i don't know if he's in there
i don't know if he's somewhere else but
whatever it is that's not
actually him and that's cool that's a
huge piece of
information because what it does is it
leads billy on this kind of trail where
he's like hold on he's like freeze that
he's like zoom in on this guy's neck and
that's when he realizes there's an
access hatch there right this is a zord
right that's all it is like it's a giant
zord i mean sure it's insanely advanced
it grows it shrinks it seems to have
capabilities and and different things
like that technologies that the zords
here
in in i guess the main uh power rangers
universe doesn't necessarily have
but at the end of the day it's still a
zord and if there's any one thing we've
learned about the zords and when it
comes to the the mighty morphin power
rangers they seem to run on
some form of electricity billy's like
okay
can you get out of here and goldar is
like i mean i control the dark dimension
and he's like but i mean can you get out
of here he's like no i'm imprisoned here
by reading repulsa now
this is an interesting thing this
changes the way that you see goldar's
character because it's one
thing to see goldar imprisoned in the
dark dimension and it's another to know
that he keeps himself there right out of
loyalty for for rita repulsa but the
cool thing here
is billy's like okay so i get you're
gonna stay here because you feel honor
bound to serve out your punishment you
know as to make amends for your failures
your past transgressions and
disappointing reader repulsa but like
can you get me out of here though and
goldar's like i mean i i guess i could
but like
why would i and billy makes this amazing
case he's like you know what i think
you're right he's like i think that
guy's form is not his actual form i
don't think that person that black
dragon
is what they claim to be sure like
there's somebody who's capable and
powerful
but they're not revealing all their
cards they still have an ace up their
sleeve somewhere he's like if it really
does have an access hatch
then it's mechanical and if it is
mechanical who knows machines
better than me right like i'm the best
person suited to figure out how to take
this guy down and so
get me out of here right give me get me
out of here get me back there i can get
this guy
defeated done out of the picture and
clear the path for you to get back into
the good graces of rita repulsa
that right there is a super convincing
argument that's one of the things that i
love about this right in the old power
rangers tv show billy was the brains but
back in the 90s it was all about
stereotypes right and so when you had a
character like billy who was the brains
of the operation
it was one of those things where he's
like he's the brain he's the nerd he's
the goof right and that and like that's
all he's gonna be
and this there's a kind of suave and and
almost a little bit of of
you know espionage type attitude to
billy right which is
pretty cool and that's why i love the
way billy's done here because ultimately
goldar is like enemies of our enemies
and
billy's like enemies of our enemies so
it's like cool so he opens a portal
billy gets out right and as soon as he
gets there he's like okay so here's the
thing
that black dragon is fully mechanical i
don't know exactly what's going on here
but i do know it's mechanical and
tommy's like what are you talking about
he's like it's basically a zord man
so like it's got an access hatch if we
can get in the access hatch of that
thing and we can get inside we can find
his power source we can shut it down
right we can we can
end this thing and so that's when
tommy's like okay cool let's do this
right the power rangers are getting
wrecked right everybody else they're
just getting crushed by this black
dragon guy right so at the end of the
day i mean they're just a distraction
right
that's why you don't really see them
they're a background thing right just
clinging on for dear life like literally
like jason's like trading on your
six watch out before ah like it's just
it's one of these things you're like
they're just getting crushed
which is admittedly kind of cool you
know it's kind of cool i don't know
about you guys but i do
kind of like seeing heroes get wrecked
by villains i don't know why
i feel like maybe it provides more
credibility to the villains i'm not
really sure especially if it's like a
foreign villain you haven't seen before
ultimately they break into the sword and
as soon as they get in there billy's
like okay so he accesses his mainframe
and he's like there's a power source
here and ultimately once they get their
hands on it they
shut it down and as soon as they do that
zord comes crashing down now
there's a problem when that happens it
starts to shrink
and as the zord begins to shrink of
course you've got billy in them they
don't shrink which means
it's literally crushing them uh like
like gonna destroy them eventually and
so what ends up happening here is that
as the zord begins to shrink down the
rest of the rangers try to get there in
time and they don't
in response the zord just kind of like
there's a giant a mass of just green
energy that's essentially a
teleportation it looks like an
explosion but billy and tommy are
effectively yanked away
and that's when you have trini who's
kind of going through the the remnants
of this rubble and it's like hey
a lot of this stuff looks familiar man
like i know this thing was called a
black dragon but like if it's a zord
then i know some of these
parts right like these are parts from
the dragonzord that's what these things
are for
like they're i don't know what this is i
don't know what's going on here but this
thing looks like a dragon sword that was
repurposed right
switch over to reader repulsa and rita's
just kind of like okay so like the
rangers have basically recovered your
body and and she's like how is that like
how are you talking to me if they
recovered your body he's like because i
was never there right like the black
dragon was basically a
thing operating on my behalf out there
it's just a vessel from my dimension but
i was never actually there
which is kind of crazy because a
question you have to ask yourself is if
the power rangers with their zords and
everything
struggled that much against the black
dragon what
chance do they have against this guy
this is made even more complicated by
the fact that he says i know exactly
where billy and tommy have been
teleported to
they've been teleported to my dimension
they've been teleported to my world and
they have no idea what they're in for
this is an alternate reality version of
the power rangers who is the white and
the green ranger combined those of you
guys who know what's going on
no spoilers but that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace